can you tell me the biggest difference
between the Adam Warlock that was first
pitched to you and who he became in the
Final Cut of the film
wow
um I mean
yeah the the
um the costume the visual effects makeup
definitely improved compared to the
addition that I sent in from home I will
say that that was a marked improvement
in the budget but um no you know outside
of that honestly you know outside of the
kind of obvious physical elements and
the CGI and all the kind of major things
that really do help to make him who he
is costume Etc character-wise I think
James always had a pretty pretty
consistent um and clear view of how he
wanted Adam to be
um and so I just tried to kind of match
up to that as best as possible was there
any particular quality of his that you
didn't discover until you were on set
also working with your co-stars and
developing those relationships he has
with them I think it wasn't until I kind
of observed the performances of like
incredible actors like Chuck and then
the Guardians and to see where they kind
of plotted themselves on a kind of moral
compass that I was sort of able to
really understand where Adam wanted to
be like it wasn't until I kind of saw
them play out their own reality that I
was you know uh it wasn't until then
that I was able to kind of uh really
kind of work out where Adam uh lied on
on the scale very much makes sense for
both of you now I get a little obsessed
with character backstory so especially
when you're playing such curious complex
characters who have clearly gone through
quite a bit to get them to the point
that we see in the movie so did you come
up with any backstory or maybe do any
research in the source material that you
found being important to your
performance that maybe we don't directly
see or hear about on screen but you
found informing your work all along the
way for me it wasn't Source material I
mean there's that whole incredible
history in the comic books of Being John
Wyndham and whatever and you know from
banished from Oxford or Cambridge it was
great to read but for me Jay I I really
like using using what's in front of me
and James has this way of creating his
own you know Bible for attacks and the
beginning middle event is there all that
what I did use that I came I would say
that I brought into that people don't
necessarily know is that I had an idea
that this guy doesn't sleep there was
something about
um the the royal guy the almost like
religious
um zealotry about him that I go what if
on top of that he's so obsessed with his
mission he doesn't sleep but that was
mainly for me and that was what made me
feel that whole thing that when I'm in
front of people
I turn it on because when I when I'm not
with them it just goes into a dark
morose place you know I love details
like that especially when even though
it's not there I can feel it and I
believe it oh good that's that's what I
was playing with I bet for you well yeah
I mean the comics were were definitely
uh helpful to me in addition to the to
the script but the script is such a
fantastic blueprint and I think James
has such an intimate you know uh
psychologically kind of appreciative
understanding of all of his characters
that you know he does a lot of work for
you in that respect
um and then as I say you know when I
turn up on set I'm really leaning on the
the strength of the performances of
other people whether it's observing
Chuck or whether it's you know watching
the Guardians kind of response to me
um I think Light Truck said it's about
kind of like getting that prep done and
then being in a position where you can
just kind of respond instinctively
you've both emphasized how uh James
plans everything out and he really kind
of walks you through it and gives you
the information you need what is the
biggest difference between you know
maybe physically or just what he
explains to you when you hit set what he
gives to you versus any other director
and writer you worked with in the past I
I love the fact that for someone who's
so prepared and storyboards everything
himself has been lives the characters is
writing them he's still completely open
to you surprising him there were so many
um my favorite scenes when I'd come home
bouncing is when you've gone you've done
a take and you've given him what he's
written and he's happy and he says okay
do whatever he always does this do
whatever you do whatever you want and
then you do and every now and then you
do something that he really loved and he
then he pushes us to the nth degree and
that you feel a new scene has come out
of the scene that was there and for it's
a weird combination for someone to be so
prepared so ready and at the same time
so flexible you know that's the that's
the gift you want as a as a performer
you know oh I have to follow up on that
so for both of you can you give me an
example a non-spoiler example of course
of like a really big swing you took when
you got that opportunity that we can now
see in the Final Cut with out spoiling
it I'm not allowed to talk about the
ending or the end credits oh really okay
um gosh it's really hard to especially
as I'm very conscious the fact that
everybody nominated me as the person who
was going to give away the most the most
yeah well I I remember one there's like
there is there is a moment in it where
um I think I don't give a way to say I'm
confronting uh rocket early on where I
realize what rocket is you know and I
had there was a piece of music I had
sent James Purcell's
[Music]
um
um remember me it's uh it's from
um I believe it's Tristan and his soul
and they use that in the soundtrack as a
sort of music and James we came on set
and we did the scene and then he put it
on the
speaker to play and play and play and he
had it Play and play and then we did
this scene and it just kept saying more
he kept saying you can go further with
it you can go and the music is playing
and it's really emotic and you go
further and further and I'm I'm I'm I'm
at the point where the adrenaline is
pumping and that scene whatever it was
beforehand went to an end degree and I
think you see it in the movie in the
soul interaction because my last line As
I Leave the Room in that
I do it sort of the high Evolution it
does is slightly exhausted I was
completely exhausted and that worked for
it does that make sense yeah yeah that
makes sense of it there's an awkward hug
in the movie which was oh yeah which was
like added in by James kind of from
behind the Monitor and we just tried it
in a number of different ways and he was
like more Awkward more awkward and I was
like there's one thing I do well it's
it's awkward so I uh yeah I I TR I had
fun with that and it was such a great
moment they all just loved it you know
they went crazy what they don't know is
I was just trying to do a normal hug why
does everyone think you're gonna give
away all the spoilers uh you know I'm
the new kid and I get it I get it I get
what it is but I'm being very tread
careful because I'm really trying to not
be that guy it's understandable I have
an important question for you that'll
help me sleep at night do you have any
pets I do I have a gorgeous dog uh
Schnoodle Schnauzer poodle mix called
Cicero who I adore and who every time I
saw
the finished rocket I saw they have the
same eyes it was really I I was
heartbroken I was completely destroyed
watching that movie because they
literally have the same eyes you know so
there's always been a lot of themes and
ideas in the Guardians movies that have
wrecked me yeah the the pet and animal
lover element here is just it's like it
gutted me while I was watching it but
I'm glad you have a wonderful pet to go
home too and that that is your reality
so when you're playing a villain in a
movie the villain never really believes
that they're a villain so for the high
evolutionary where do you think that he
draws the line between right and wrong
if he does it all is there a line he
won't cross I I sort of mentioned the
word zealotry and I I don't think
there's a line he won't cross if he
believes it's gonna get you there you
know the um
there he does believe that he is he is
the only one that can bring uh
civilization to the next level and save
it very famous like almost like but in a
very
scary way so I don't think there's a
line and that was the joy of playing him
it's not you know I'm not sort of
pretending and winking at the audience
that don't worry there's a line we'll do
another movie and I'll be much nicer no
this guy
is completely disturbing and it was it
was completely delicious to play that
delicious is such a good descriptor
there he's he's so incredibly disturbing
but I can't explain why it was so joyful
to watch you just like go to the nth
degree and go big with that character
here's my overly sentimental question
that I love asking now because in this
industry we give each other Awards and
that's wonderful but I don't think
anybody says good job to themselves
nearly enough so what is something you
accomplish in this movie that you can
now look back on and say like damn I am
proud of what I did there oh my gosh
that is that is a really difficult thing
to ask it's a challenge with purpose
though yeah I mean oh man I um
honestly I'm glad there were some days I
was shooting with Nico Santos and Miriam
Shaw I'm glad I actually managed to pull
off that scene finally because I was
laughing so hard doing it yeah there
were so many days where I almost laughed
myself into
um getting fired yeah it was great that
I finished off the scenes
that's so true I I would I would maybe
second that and say like you know there
are there are times where Sean Gunn was
throwing out alts you know to me and and
and it's such a such an Adept improviser
uh Chris to you know that when that was
being thrown at you pelted with you know
funny stones and you can sort of hold it
together yeah which is something I think
bringing it together
holding it together they're finishing up
a deal filming and you manage to yeah
still be employed because you haven't
screwed up is is a good thing but you
know yeah I'll let you guys get away
with those answers there's a mile long
list of exceptional performance beats on
this you should be very proud
congratulations on the movie thank you
so thank you so much